J NEILSON: Smiths, welcome to
our strength test.
I'm going to take each of
your multi-purpose blades
and I'm going to
pry, hammer, and chop
into these nails and spikes.
I want to see what they're
going to do to your blades.
I'm not too concerned what
your blades do to them.
Nicholas, you're up first.
How are you feeling?
NICHOLAS: A little nervous.
J NEILSON: We're
going to do it anyway.
NICHOLAS: I know, I know.
J NEILSON: OK, let's do it.
[music playing]
NICHOLAS: I'm feeling
as nervous as I felt
going into this competition.
But I'm fairly
confident in the edge.
I'm very confident
in the hammer.
If those pry teeth hold up,
I might just stand a chance.
[music playing] [hammering]
J NEILSON: All right Nicholas,
we've got a couple issues here.
During the pry it popped
off one of your teeth here.
And it actually, instead of
pulling the nail out further,
it actually buried the head
further into the wood block.
Now coming over to the hammer
strike, having this down here,
it's like taking
a hammer at home,
cutting the handle off and
just trying to use that.
That's big design
flaw right there.
On the plus side, your blade
edge held up pretty well.
Mark, how are you feeling
after seeing that?
MARK: Tear it up.
J NEILSON: Oh,
don't tell me that.
MARK: I'm feeling
excited and nervous.
I hope my blade doesn't explode.
But either way I'm
in a good mood.
[music playing]
[hammering]
J NEILSON: Mark,
overall I like this.
The pry tines were
a little bit tight.
I had to actually wedge it in
there to get that nail out.
Problem I have is
the hammerhead.
It's not that much wider
than the nail heads itself.
So it's really hard getting
an accurate strike on there.
On your edge, it actually
held up pretty well.
You've got little
wrinkles there.
But overall, everything
stayed tight.
Good job.
MARK: Cool.
Thank you.
J NEILSON: So Garrin,
how are you feeling?
GARRIN: I'm feeling a little bit
more nervous than I was before.
J NEILSON: OK.
Well, let's see
what happens here.
[music playing]
GARRIN: When I saw
Nicholas's fork break,
I thought, Oh God, this
can't be good for me.
I've got the same steel.
I've got the same design.
So I'm worried about the same
exact thing happening for me.
[music playing]
J NEILSON: All right
Garrin, obviously we
got a problem here.
It was such a clean
break, what I'm thinking
is you probably had some kind
of microfracture in the edge
that we couldn't even see.
Trying to lever it up, the teeth
we're just burying in the wood.
So when I tried to jam it in
and lever it up the other way,
bang.
That's when we blow apart.
WIL WILLIS: Nicholas,
Garrin, both of you
had a problem in
the strength test.
Nicholas, your blade
suffered significant damage
by losing one of the teeth.
However, we were able to do
the chop test with your blade.
Garrin, your blade
snapped in half.
That is catastrophic
blade damage
and you can no
longer even continue
with our strength test.
And for that reason I
have to ask you, Garrin,
to please leave the forge.
GARRIN: [bleep] I'm
feeling pretty [bleep]..
I agree with the decision
that the judges made.
But I really wanted to see
Doug do a cutting test.
Knives are not crowbars,
tell your friends.
[music playing]